foreign
[Music]
Bots and kind of what they can do I
think they're kind of cute and kind of
fun I had no clue that
um people would literally not want to
come to the restaurant because I had a
robot
[Music]
foreign
I have always loved the casadero and the
beautiful view my first wedding
anniversary was here and so when it
became for sale I had a son who was in
the industry and was interested in
management so we purchased it and been
here ever since as the cost of minimum
wage keeps increasing and increasing and
our business was increasing but not
enough to be able to bring in another
server or another bartender I was like
how do you even run a restaurant and
keep all sides happy
being able to bring in another server
was impossible because then you're in
the hole just for opening up your door
and so I started looking into technology
to see if I can assist uh and provide a
tool and so I went to the restaurant and
bar Expo with the main purpose of
looking into robots and there were about
four vendors there and so I ended up
coming home leasing a robot
Plato lives right here when the food is
up and the bartender can't come they
just come over here click what table
and off he goes
Plano is a robot that is a tool to help
my servers and my bartenders and the
customers and so when we are very busy
we don't have a tree which backup
servers and bartenders on it so uh in
order to best serve the customers what
our bartenders and servers are able to
do is be with our customers be with our
guests to get their orders and answer
questions and if somebody else's food is
in the window Plato will be able to take
it out rather than it getting colder the
window he's there as a tool to help
assist our bartenders and servers
I was so excited I put it on Facebook
and uh we immediately I mean I think I
got more negative than positive comments
that they would not come here it was all
Facebook 100 on Facebook
it blew me away it blew me away and
there was so much it was all because
they thought it was replacing somebody
and it wasn't and that's what was so
frustrating is the misunderstanding that
uh AI is replacing people's jobs the
robot is not replacing humans I have
servers and servers will never go away
these robots are not running around
taking over the restaurant and you just
see you know AI everywhere
um this the server positions the
bartender positions are still there this
is just a tool to help them do their job
better and be more efficient for the
guests and make a better guest
experience
there we go
I like Plato I think he's pretty neat I
say hi to him every time he comes by I
know he can't answer but
no mama so many people like there he is
you rub between his nose and his his
eyes turn like into hearts or something
and he smiles just a look on their face
you know it kind of surprises a lot of
people and the little kids love him
it's just being a help to the restaurant
itself
but they can't do anything that you
don't tell them to do
for example with Plato there's a screen
there's a map and you tell it where to
go and it goes there and it comes back
it's not going to do something
unexpected that's its job it's just to
do something very specific and come back
the early adopters are definitely the
small restaurant owners like the
casadero with Sherry here and it's
because they see value in it they have a
staffing issue where maybe there's just
only one or two people working at the
time and this is going to help them get
food out a little bit quicker and be
that tool and I would say so smaller
shops but anything from upstate New York
down to Florida all the way out here
into the West Coast they're being
deployed
and I come down here just to see that
like I said you know I've heard some
skeptical stuff about it I go
hey that's modern times you know and
it's not cutting back on anybody's job
here it's just help when they're
short-handed
the one thing that did happen that kind
of broke my heart was tips went down
some servers have chosen not to use them
for that because this is their
livelihood and they rely on those tips
we like being our little rural community
and they don't want to see new
technology coming in that being said we
are growing we've doubled in size and
the people moving here are moving from
Mississippi from Portland area and
coming here and they love it so as much
as we might hate to say we're changing
our Dynamic and our demographic is
definitely changing and you can't please
everybody you want to I want to make
everybody happy
but we definitely are small town
foreign
[Music]